[Music]
I want to thank you for to come this
evening but you will see a good picture
I saw 15 years ago it's so good and
before we start for those of you who may
remember a certain moment in the movie
Kirk I am Spartacus
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow you were all in the movie huh
impressive I bet you haven't seen that
before the whole what you did the
Writers Guild in 1991 honored you for
your part in breaking the Hollywood
blacklist by hiring yes
but you know you have no idea how
terrible
fifty years ago when we have the
blacklist it was a center stone and the
heaven would and I also blame the heads
of the children at that time because
they came in to the man of crisis but
mcclure sake I was much younger them and
I have they always said I have angular
it wouldn't be Santa cookies or so I'm
just scribbling they're saying the whole
situation and people said it don't they
were from both name he wasn't ever
working when I visit in spite of that in
this described before I mean people
wasn't says but the black face was old
so when you see this green and when they
said Wilson my door for Trumbo
the studio was scared to death of
Spartacus and they gave you a list of
things you couldn't do let me just read
some of this the costumes of the slaves
will have to offer adequate covering the
whipping is in danger of proving
excessively brutal we ask that you
eliminate this particular use of the
word damn we asked it to eliminate the
use of the word damn the loin cloth
costumes must prove adequate I love that
this goes on and on and on I mean of all
the things they told you to cut out well
[Music]
you know 95 years old you don't look
forward you know the fun of decimation
when you look backward if you take
inventory I found that I was very proud
to be a member of the health community
because in-house distance inept
Republican or Democrat you're American
well guys like your Clooney
sit so pen and the Zoey over who go out
and spend their money here to help other
people and spend their time and whenever
access to work in their other cuz we
know buddy she's healthy over a real
Paul Gruber and then request their city
of him of America so I'm thinking we
have when too many Republican too many
Democrats and now I live I'm working
[Applause]